people think the clear cuts are bad
because it's destroying a significant
area of forest in a short amount of time
our practices actually mimic those of
nature even before the area was settled
there were wind storms such as tornadoes
fires droughts ice storms that caused
natural havoc on the lake in general we
tend to look upon for us that have been
cut as ugly we see a field full of
stumps as being a sign of devastation
sustainable forestry in the most basic
sense is simply managing the forest so
that you can get some sort of product
out of it and yet it can continue
producing that product indefinitely in
the future the clear-cutting at the turn
of the century was entirely different it
was simply an extractive industry and
didn't care about wildlife they didn't
care about regeneration they didn't care
about ecosystems
the wood that we produce here comes from
well-managed sustainable forests and by
that I mean that it is third-party
independently looked at to see that we
have protected the environment taking
care of the ecosystems protected the
biodiversity of the various species
within the forest our global positioning
system consists of a backpack unit and
an antenna along with a data recorder
that a forester carries with him the
trees with the orange bands are what we
call our long-term residuals they're not
going to be harvested now or in the
future at all the trees with the green
bands are here to drop seed for
seedlings and also to provide disperse
light so those seeds can germinate and
the seedling development we have to
balance all of those uses with what we
know will do to perpetuate the forest in
the future
100% of the products from our woods
certified if a consumer would look at
two boards that were from the same
species same size and thickness and
grade you would not see any difference
between a certified piece of lumber and
one that is not certified the difference
would be from the heart when you would
see one that was certified you would
know that it was from a well-managed for
us